hey Matlin wani oversees the production
of clothes for his designer label and
his workshop and author Pradesh sales
fell by 70% in the past two months
during lockdown and Heyman says he'll
have to lay off around 75 of his 300
employees the suspension of most of the
state's labor laws means he no longer
needs the government's permission to
fire staff in this difficult time their
industry is already suffering a lot with
huge losses Myers canceling orders this
is what was very important support that
we got from the government utter pradesh
which is home to 230 million people is
one of many states to change its labor
laws including getting rid of the
minimum wage extended working hours and
reducing employee benefits the state say
the changes will help businesses and get
the world's fifth largest economy back
on track but workers are already paying
the price as soon as the changes were
announced savage kamar was fired from
the woman's wear factory he's worked in
for four years work is continuing at the
company and 800 two thousand people are
working new workers have been hired on
daily wages and none of those who used
to work at the company have been brought
back trade unions say the revised laws
will drive down wages in a country where
the minimum is just over $2 a day union
leaders defied lockdown guidelines to
protest in New Delhi which police
quickly dispersed the biggest changes
have been in states ruled by Prime
Minister Narendra Modi's part at the
Ajanta party critics say the
government's using the economic slump to
push through laws it's planned since
first being elected six years ago and at
a time when people aren't allowed to
protest the International Labour
Organization has warned
100 million Indians could slip into
poverty as a result of India's lockdown
and is urging Prime Minister Modi to
send a clear message to states to uphold
labor laws and protect workers from
exploitation
Elizabeth puranam al Jazeera New Delhi